what is it oh my gonna statue yeah
[Music]
fragile a must be Italian I'm pretty
good lines from a Christmas story
you know the olive a classic turns 35 on
Sunday and in case you're wondering
whatever happened to our favorite pink
bunny Ralphie and some of the rest of
the cast well wonder no more
it's our Friday flashback I want an
official bedrock of an action to annex
young minds of all arrived it's about a
little boy growing up in about 1939 or
40 and it takes place about three weeks
before Christmas and it's about a boy
who wants a BB gun for Christmas Ralphie
was the role of a lifetime for Peter
Billingsley and that BB gun was super
special it's a Red Ryder cooing and shot
range model air rifle and so I go to my
mother for it I go to my teacher fort
and I go to Santa Claus for it and they
all tell me that I'm gonna shoot my eye
out
I don't anybody shoot his eye out
[Music]
Alfie's nemesis was bad boy Scott played
by Zach Ward it's a gift that keeps on
giving every single year I become that
long-lost family member that everyone
likes seeing again and they laugh and
they smile and they give me a hug and
I've never met these people but they
spent their entire lives watching this
film and enjoying watching me get beat
up and bleeding on the ground as for
Peter today he still acts that's him in
Iron Man
buddy you're not a cotton-headed
ninny-muggins he had a role in elves and
appeared in the breakup with Jennifer
Aniston and Vince Vaughn where he also
executive produced I had the good
fortune of working with Vince quite a
few times we met originally back on an
after-school special many many years ago
and he's a lot of fun but having a
Christmas story continued as an iconic
holiday classic will probably always be
Peters legacy oh my god I shot my eye
out
[Music]
[Applause]